the US government tells us that the
government of El Salvador is a budding
democracy a little bit flawed but
they're making good progress
whereas Nicaragua's communist
totalitarian state well you don't see
much of on the media of people who
actually have had experience in
Nicaragua and El Salvador coming back
and saying what they saw and what
they've experienced right now in
alternative views we have Kathleen
Stockwell is going to do just that for
us Kathleen has traveled in El Salvador
and has had extensive experience in
Nicaragua so tonight we're going to show
you some slides which she took in both
countries and she's going to compare the
two countries and what she has seen and
what she's experienced Kathleen you this
is your second time in El Salvador but
the other was just kind of passing
through very quickly but you've had
extensive traveling experiences and
working done in Nicaragua can you give
us a brief history of your experience in
those two countries yes and Nicaragua I
was just heading south with my backpack
essentially and stopped in Nicaragua and
was really interested in what was going
on and acquired a job helping to
translate some articles from English to
Spanish and Spanish to English and ended
up staying for about six months and when
was it that was in 84 and since then
I've been so fascinated and I made so
many friends that I've been back
virtually every year since then and one
of my trips back was buy land and I went
through El Salvador and it was really a
horrifying experience because there is a
very real war in the countryside in El
Salvador and this time this summer was
the first time I'd ever been with a
group of people and
I took a tortilla salvador and nicaragua
this summer it was a comparative study
tour and we had a real impressive
experience most Americans don't know
that you can fly into Nicaragua without
a visa you can just go to the Houston
Airport San Antonio left for buy a
ticket and fly directly to Nicaragua get
off the plane no trouble at a sporting
well yeah you do have to have a passport
but you don't need a visa whereas to go
to El Salvador I think you do have to
have a visa there's much more
restriction on travel in fact there's a
lot of areas of El Salvador you simply
can't go because the civil war there is
so intense he had a they checked us over
thoroughly before everybody in the tour
had to try and even a little description
of themselves to get the visa to go to
El Salvador and we had to do it a month
in advance to be sure we could get the
permission it was much more difficult
than Nicaragua where I've always gone
with no forewarning whatsoever let's
take a look at some of the slides that
you took of El Salvador and Nicaragua
and we'll share your experience okay
our group was basically just Texans and
from all walks of life just interested
in the situation because not feeling
like they had enough information from
our own media and the two-week tour was
right in the middle of summer when a lot
of people have have a break time and I
want to say first that El Salvador is a
beautiful country it's all volcanoes and
lakes and forests and the people
actually live and survive up in these
dense forests and have their villages in
their home life up there and the
government that is why the guerrilla
force has been so strong against the
government is that it's so dense and so
thick it does remind people a lot of
Vietnam and therefore is compared to
Vietnam because you can't just wipe out
the whole country although they're still
trying well now when you were there you
saw in the streets a lot of evidence of
resistance of people communicating with
graffiti there which was an interesting
thing isn't it yes
the main method of public outcry is
break hands and graffiti actually I
probably don't have spiked hands they
probably just use paintbrushes and for
lack of the materials and we did see one
demonstration down there where people
during the demonstration which is there
were people on the sides of the
demonstration who had just run alongside
and spray some a message on every wall
all the way up and down when the
government had its own propaganda the
posters and all what would the people do
with that what they term down or just
write graffiti over there well as
posters get aged you know you can't be
witnessed doing anything to the
government posters but the government
has posters all over the place as well
that are professionally rendered and
they are up glorifying the army and
joining the army
and and and present presenting evidence
and pictures against the guerrillas the
FMLN and with pictures of children that
have been mined whereas there is a lot
of mining going on by both sides they
the government is of course blaming all
the mining on the guerrillas I think it
was real appropriate that one of the
first stops of the group was going to
the US Embassy because the US Embassy
has so much to do with the running of
the government in El Salvador several
times the man who was speaking to our
group referred to El Salvador or
something that would happen in El
Salvador he would say well we can't
permit we you know referring to the US
government as having the ultimate
control of what goes on and there are he
said that there are 55 military trainers
in El Salvador now that's a big lie of
course yes and his presentation was very
cold and and bugged the country in two
sections and was very impersonal didn't
refer to the people at all to the
situation but it was it was a real
interesting stop for us did people
challenge his opinions or questioned US
policy at all in your group we were told
when we went to the embassy that just
for the sake of the group that gave us
the tour not to be argumentative because
they get criticisms later they get a
letter from the government from the US
Embassy saying what they thought of that
group yeah they brought and so we could
ask questions that we weren't to be
confrontational or argue were you
harassed at all by the local police or
government or military yes we were very
nervous being in El Salvador because we
were harassed immediately as we came in
and detained for a couple of hours in
the airport and then the one the
organizer of the tour came and got us
and talked our way in and told them what
we were going to do and all during the
tour we had to be very careful about who
we spoke to
we had to be careful about what we said
we couldn't use words like peace we
couldn't mention certain countries
while you were traveling around while we
were in there and we were followed and
people were listening to his people were
posted to listen to us in the hotel we
were and and in restaurants that we
would go to so it was not a free feeling
at all we were real frightened and we
were afraid of you know we're used to
being free and easy here in the States
and so when you go and you have to be in
a more controlled situation put on a
different mentality
you're constantly slipping and you're
constantly slipped you know hearing
yourself say something you weren't
supposed to say that was audible or
you're always afraid of risking somebody
else's life not so much your own by what
you say to them or around them now how
does that compare when you were
traveling in Nicaragua then and
Nicaragua was a huge contrast as soon as
we got to Nicaragua we could relax it
seemed like people were laughing again
you know on the streets and and we could
split up and go wherever we wanted as
individuals without fearing for each
other's lives and we're you followed
they're like shitty were not in
Nicaragua no we couldn't we couldn't
distinguish anybody who was there to
listen to us or follow us at all el
sábado yeah what about the everyday life
in El Salvador the people could be a
very hard life to live in El Salvador
the people have a visible stress and
strain on them you can see it in their
eyes there's very little joy or laughter
there and there's a large amount of
poverty and we'll be getting into that
on some of the slides the human rights
situation in El Salvador is is [ __ ]
Indus there were there was a lot of
testimony from people who had had their
family members disappeared as they say
where they come and just take them at
night from eating dinner or whatever and
there are a lot of outright slaughters
where people are lined off lined up and
just machete door shot into a ditch it
was just really shocking to even think
about that sort of thing going on but
it's very common and everyone has lost a
family member due to that sort of thing
in El Salvador there's an awful lot of
torture that goes on in the prison yes
the criminal justice system is horrible
they have said when somebody's arrested
they don't even have to tell them why
they're arrested they're immediately put
15 days in incommunicado
and they indigo an interrogation at the
end of which which usually includes
torture at the end of the interrogation
they're usually asked to sign a blank
piece of paper and then whatever the
government wants to accuse the mobis
type tone above their signature as
confession last fall there were 1200
political prisoners that were taken and
they and and when you compare that to
accusations of Nicaragua taking
political prisoners it's insignificant
compared to what they do in El Salvador
with no repercussions and no way out not
to mention the 80,000 people that the
death squads have done away with over
the past few years in El Salvador
yeah it's actually more than that I'm
afraid is it so this is still going on
the political arrests in El Salvador in
the death squads it's claimed to be at a
lesser degree right now like it's a lull
in the war but it is still going on and
the system has not changed and yeah I
read somewhere administration
spokesperson saying well there are only
about 25 people a month or 35 people a
month being killed by the des quad so
that's good progress that's what the
Ambassador told us too the only the
Human Rights Commission that's
independent from the government we spoke
to a representative from it and they
said that the only justice that was ever
done on any of these arrests or
massacres or death squad annihilations
of people the only justice done on any
of them was the one that was required by
the US pressure after the four nuns were
killed all of the thousands and
thousands of people that have been
killed the innocent people that have
been killed have had no repercussion to
justice and no one has been brought out
and put into jail because of the
killings opened and the death squads
include police and government people as
well as right-wing vigilante groups in
fact a lot of the dust squads have been
trained by the CIA yeah four years back
matter of fact the head of the death
squads was almost put in to be elected
president to doubly song but he was so
controversial that
us had to negate him and now he's the
head of the right-wing party that we
also went to visit the oh you visited it
yeah we saw that we saw you saw don't
assign himself yeah what happened what
you talked about we asked them questions
about what you know their feeling was
about what was going on in the country
and their solution was purely military
they agreed with all the other groups
that we met with during our tour that
the main thing that needed to be done
was us control to be removed from the
government of El Salvador and but there
are only difference between that and
other peoples was that they wanted more
military money and more military
equipment but less control over what
they did with it
well Reagan wants to give them a 150 or
200 million more just for their police
in there and the army there of course
the reason Dobis all wants the Americans
out because the Americans are supporting
Duarte also they put some restraints on
his death squad @ks so it would be
better for him not to have any
constraints at all well understand in
the past couple of years or so the
biggest mass atrocity has been the big
bombings by the El Salvadoran Air Force
sponsored and supported by the u.s. of
the people who are out in the
countryside yes and a little bit later
we will be going into a trip we took out
to the goes up a volcano where the
Phoenix operation has been going on as
late as 86 last year they call it
Phoenix there the Phoenix is an ironic
because it's the same name that that the
Americans used for their huge death
squat operation in Vietnam which
slaughtered up to 50 or 80,000 people
and it hasn't changed in nature either
El Salvador is suffering right now
especially the capital in San Salvador
from the earthquake damage since they
did have a fairly recent earthquake and
of course they're little aid has gone to
rebuilding and rebuilding the housing
and a lot of people are homeless because
of it one community that we did get to
visit was called April 22nd community
and
this was an influx of people that had no
place to go they were coming in from the
war several years ago and they took over
a large area of land on the edge of town
and of between a highway and a train
track and it's it's like a huge ghetto
and they've just put shacks together
from parts it's just whatever scrap they
can find on the streets of the city and
the houses are very close together the
only thing between them is a small area
that you could walk through and which I
usually has a trickling stream of sewer
going down it there's no facilities for
education or there's sanitary facilities
all they'd have in there is what they
create themselves and they are doing
some things for that how many people are
in this area Oh thousands
I'd be real difficult to estimate I'd
say 5,000 off of the top of my head
although it's always changing there are
during earthquake I'm sure more people
went there to build you know even
tighter quarters in that area and people
some people are leaving now to try to go
and repopulate where they were chased
from during the war trying to to get
back in there doing anything to help
their own condition since the government
isn't doing anything for them oh they
certainly are they have a day care
program where women that aren't going
into town or volunteering to have to
take care of the children so other women
can go in and and sell things on the
streets or whatever they can to bring in
a pittance to help their family out they
are they are trying to initiate classes
they are creating crafts so that they
can sell to tourists and to stores and
in the market so they can raise some
money in order to get their sanitation
taken care of and different things that
are needed what's the general employment
situation in the country is it mass
unemployment e % unemployment 77 is
really grim everyday life there and they
don't have a nice job like public
services to help these people they
really don't have any there's no social
security
there's no public services like we used
to and have that help and housing
education the health and the housing and
the education are the lowest
they're totally catastrophic
economically the health budget is the
same it was 15 years ago and the
population since then has has grown
several times over how does this compare
with Nicaragua as far as health and
education is concerned and Nicaragua of
course has are well-known reforms that
were done in health and education and a
huge amount of the populace is literate
now and the child mortality and the life
expectancy are much greater the child
mortality is less than that life
expectancy is greater than before
because of the focus that the
Sandinistas have put on improving those
areas and what about unemployment in
Nicaragua do you have a feel for that
I'm not sure what the figures are on
that but it's the same as most
third-world countries a lot of people do
work in the markets and a lot of people
are working different odd jobs but you
find you don't find people that aren't
working and everyone is fed because
everyone is guaranteed certain certain
things rice and beans for one there are
like six guaranteed items that people
get even if there are no more you know
in the war economy often you have a lot
of shortages and rationing and but
rather than calling rationing the people
say oh these are guaranteed to us and so
they know if they don't have anything
they certainly got enough to keep them
alive and this is that communist
dictatorship that they yeah alright the
US government talks about compared to El
Salvador where they don't do anything
for ya the poverty in the economy in
Nicaragua is atrocious but the people
somebody told me at least we're not
Honduras for example in Honduras with
America our government has put in
millions of dollars in military aid
nothing has gone down to the people and
under and people are starving now you
went to the palace the government a
governmental palace in El Salvador how
did you get in there and what was the
spots to the people whom did you see we
had an interview with the Minister of
Interior and it was really impressive to
us to see their attitude it was a very
opulent environment if the cows had also
undergone some damage from the
earthquake but that that damage was
being repaired and the rooms were it was
like being in one of those ancient
castles with ornate sculpture and and
but of course the modern all the modern
carpeting and furniture that you would
expect and this very expensively dressed
men came and gave us his feeling of what
was going on in the country and he
expressed his concern over the economic
situation but I also gauged a great deal
of disdain on his part for the poor and
for the general population population
and he he actually said that he quoted
to us you know he was speaking in
English whereas a lot of our interviews
were in Spanish he said you know the
common idea in the States
that Latin American people are very lazy
he said that's especially true here in
El Salvador these unions and people that
are demanding more money and are
demanding health health rights and
insurance from their Union from their
jobs are actually just lazy people they
just are not working enough and in Latin
America having been to the other
countries in Latin America El Salvador
is held up as being the country where
the people are the most industrious and
the most hard-working you know as far as
as opinions go about how they how they
actually are so I was real really
disappointed to hear this coming from
somebody who was in charge of the
government it's not surprising though
there's been a lot of repression of
unions and union leadership in El
Salvador hasn't there yes there
certainly has we had some bitter
experiences ourselves while we were down
there some demonstrations began while we
were there that we actually without
meaning to
came too close to the day we went to the
palace there was a demonstration in
front of the palace and they the
demonstration grew and it was people
demanding they had a list of demands for
their job it was the Social Security
office which is actually more of a
militia than a Social Security doesn't
mean that you get a guarantee it's a
different sort of system but they were
protesting and they were had a walkout
of their job and they were having the
parades and demands were all sorts of
things including maternity leave and a
higher wage and and it was it was not
anything outrageous that was demanded
about three days after we left El
Salvador while we were in Nicaragua we
read a paper that that gave us an
account of a demonstration that came
after the ones that we had seen after
the ones that had been building up where
the soldiers had opened fire and had
killed several people and arrested some
more and so it was real shocking to us
to have been so close to the beginning
of that and to feel more in touch with
the the problems that the country was
having a lot of labour leaders who have
been killed by the death squads - and
there yes anyone who organizes or is a
leader of any kind can pretty much
expect to be harassed or disappeared
including religious leaders one of the
most famous of course is the bishop
Romero who was assassinated while he was
giving a mass in church yes and we did
go to the church his church where he was
assassinated and visited his tomb in
there and it was a real moving
experience knowing what we did at this
point okay let's talk about the cold
madres we hear a lot about them can you
tell us about them and what that mean
the commandos is the organization of
mothers of the disappeared they were so
frustrated in losing their family
members that a group of women got
together and decided to organize and
and open up files and try to find the
missing people and they do they have to
do difficult things like go to the dump
the body dumps and try to recognize
people and take pictures and when people
are found on the side of the street that
have been assassinated they they go and
try to find out who they are right away
recently
let's bring their office was bombed and
a lot of the files were burned that they
had so carefully accumulated now they're
in a borrowed office space which is very
cramped right down the street but it's
just real shocking to us that a group of
mothers who is trying to find people who
is not doing a political activist
specifically a political activist
program is bombed by right-wing squads
this one's again with Nicaragua there
any death squads that are operating in
Nicaragua outside of the countries no
there were many death squads under
Somoza and people still remember not
being able to take dates out at night
and Nicaragua because of the fear of
being pulled over being pulled out of
your house at night and being killed for
no reason
but now there are not fact I visited the
region in Nicaragua where they used to
dump the dead bodies that were killed by
samosas death squads and evidently
there's similar regions in El Salvador
outside of the city where periodically
you find stacks of bodies the death
squads had killed on a given day a week
yeah recently in California they've had
some hearings due to the new AI NS the I
NS immigration laws where people from El
Salvador have had to go in and do
lengthy testimony in front of judges to
show that they really do deserve
political asylum because of the
situation and I was just reading one
where a man was lined up and shot in on
top of one of those body dumps in and
jumped off before he was hit I think it
was by a machete actually and and woke
up among the bodies but stayed quiet
until the police left and then
gave to the country and now our
government is trying to send them back
and so well did you stay in El Salvador
though I mean in San Salvador the whole
time or did you travel out into the
countryside much no we stayed in San
Salvador for most of our meetings with
the groups and the unions to get a feel
for what was going on you know we were
visiting all all from the right to the
left and well actually you can't really
visit any organized left because they're
not allowed but the human rights and the
education and the health and we went out
and got military permission at a base to
go to the Guapo volcano where the
Phoenix operations have been going on
for so many years in an area where it
used to be a guerrilla stronghold or is
it still a guerrilla strzepa volcano is
20 miles from the capital San Salvador
and the guerrillas were holding it for a
long period of time in 84 when I was in
San Salvador I could hear the bombing on
on the goes up a volcano just 20 miles
an hour away and and now the bombing is
is not happening any longer to the point
where a group of people went back to
repopulate the cooperative that they had
been living on for so many years before
that before they had to evacuate we went
to getting up to the goes up a volcano
every house in every village that we
went through on the road was destroyed
by a bomb and I was shocked you know
I've never been through a bombed out
area before really and I was shocked
that they could hit every single
building you know I didn't realize that
there was that good aim you know or that
had been that extensive that it could
wipe out everything when we got to the
co-operative they we found out that they
had been a community a large town of
about 10,000 people and 7,000 of those
people had either been killed or
displaced as refugees in another country
by the by the war everyone had left the
whole ten thousand had
and and but they couldn't account for
about 7,000 of them and about 500 had
moved back and we're trying to rebuild
some homes and get their community going
again so that they wouldn't have to be
living as in the slums around the cities
well does they organize their own
community or did the government come in
and control it they had a lot of
difficulty even getting to their place
they were stopped by the military and
and Americans that were with them or
actually Europeans that would be with
them that were trying to help them get
up through as you know being protection
by being foreigners were sent away so
they were left alone with the military
and they just kept discussing and
finally the resettlement was permitted
by the government in the military and
then they just started doing it on their
own from sanitation to education to farm
working to everything the government
often would send somebody in and say
well we would like to have somebody in
here to help you do the sanitation and
they would say well we have it taken
care of you can see we have all
everybody's got their own own system
going and and then they would send
somebody and say well we would like this
person to be your teacher and they were
always trying to send somebody from the
government in order to always be there
in the village to report on the village
and they never would always had
everything taken care of until finally
now they just send military through in
the military periodically patrol and
just go through by surprise looking in
all the doors and and the guerrillas
don't operate in that area anymore that
huh not not in the way they were before
the Phoenix operation did you get a
sense of what the military situation was
in terms of the war had the guerrillas
been active at the time that you were
there was the war fairly intense or was
it more quiet there well it's in the
beginnings close to some dialogue when
we were going there and actually there
has been some since we were there they
figures that I know of are that the
government has 51
thousand troops I understand and the
guerrillas have more like 46 but then
you can also count for the guerrillas
the masses that support them and the
militia that are in the villages and if
you were going to count those so
actually it's pretty balanced or
actually heavier on the guerrilla side
which is why the US military is is so
much what the government is based on so
the dialogue so there so the guerrillas
do have enough strength to be able to
create the need for death for the
government to have dialogue so I'm
really happy to see some sort of
dialogue going on now the government
back in what was the 1982 where they
attacked and destroyed the university of
san salvador did you visit that area yes
we did go to the University and it has
reopened only due to the initiative of
the students who have raised the money
and rebuilt me and put up tents and and
gotten some books and and are having the
classes going again everyone at the
university was very young you know even
the professor's most everyone else had
had been killed before or was more
easily intimidated than the youth who
were trying to learn the university had
been a center of resistance for the
government which is why it was attacked
and leveled and as we know universities
here in the states were the center for
resistance during the Vietnam War for
example so they are rebuilding and and
appealing to the United States students
to send them books to rebuild their
library and the library was just almost
completed how all the books were
destroying yes well notice in the
pictures that there is graffiti inside
the walls Pro guerrilla graffiti enough
was that put in after the students
reoccupied it there probably before and
after they a lot of the buildings that
they might try to reoccupy they're not
even safe walking in the even though
they were bombed out by the military the
earthquake as well did more damage so a
lot of they they use some buildings
but mostly they use tents and any
buildings or any walls that are
available or definitely spray-painted
and there's still a lot of activism in
the university and there's also a lot of
repression going on again let's talk
about Nicaragua now you've spent so much
time down there over the past several
years what does it like now after all
these years of struggle and trying to
keep the country together in spite of
the fact of the war going on well
Nicaragua is a wonderful place to be it
there's a lot of going there for us as a
group it was like breathing a sigh of
relief you know now we can relax you
know now we can wander around and do
what we want and the people there though
definitely stressed out because the
economy is the seven hundred percent
percent inflation whereas to show you a
concrete example of what's happened to
their money system the Cordoba used to
go 160 for $1 would be the exchange and
now it's up to four thousand four
thousand cordobas to the dollar on the
black market
so for us to buy to pay a meal at the
restaurant it was like opening up the
suitcase that you've stolen from the
bank you had to count out all these
bills in order to to pay and it was
really outrageous and the people are
feeling it too the people are really
stressed out economically they've got
their guarantees their rations if you
will but not much else and it's really
hard to afford anything else and well
they do have this safety net as you were
talking about the guarantee of food they
have health benefits and they have
education free health and free education
yeah
but then it was this rift where somebody
told me at least we're not Honduras I
mean at this point we're the worst
they've ever been economically they're
still better off than their neighbors
who were being doing u.s. money when I
went down there this summer they told us
that 52 percent of their budget went
towards the military to fight the Contra
war and approximately 50 percent of
their labor power was devoted to war
related activity which was just
crippling them economically the first
couple years of the Sandinista regime
they made the most impressive economic
process progress in Latin America they
had the highest rate of growth they had
this successful literacy and health
campaigns but this has really been
hampered by the Contra war so to some
extent reagan has succeeded in his aim
of making life difficult at least for
the Nicaraguans if not overthrowing the
Sandinista government so it's just
several years of war that have taken
their toll yeah that's the whole purpose
of the contrast the whole purpose of the
countries is to stress out the economy
and stress out the country and that's
why they use terrorism they it used to
be more abled base to be able to use
terrorism in a more secret way but we
can get all of this negative publicity
here in the States but the purpose of
the Contras is to to make the country so
miserable that that it succumbs and that
it kicks out its own government and so
necessarily when you're under that kind
of pressure you lean further and further
to the left so rather than creating a
democracy which we easily could by
offering humanitarian aid instead we're
creating we're creating a more left to
state whereas they started out as as a
social democracy and a very comparable
to Costa Rica you know they have to get
more and more aid from the left from the
east side Mehsud by for survival and
that makes them angrier and angrier at
our capitalist system and make in and so
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy and then
at this point Reagan can point a finger
and say see you know they're becoming
more Marxist now whereas it's it's our
own it's our own crews Affairs that's
creating it Susilo doesn't but on the
other hand
it used to be that there were 60% of the
economy in private hands 40 in
government hands as has changed no
they're still there still maintaining
all of the looks because a very social
democratic economy and they're making
all the compromises and and all of the
offerings that they can as and and to me
I don't know if I would be able to do
that if I was a Nicaraguan I'm
constantly angered by things like the
amnesty program recently it got a
tomorrow the the leader one of the
leaders of the countries has accepted
the Nicaraguan amnesty program under the
peace plan and whereas Nicaragua has had
an open amnesty welcoming back any
Contras to reintegrate for four or five
years now and and but that's never been
recognized or acknowledged by now you
never hear about the democratic election
they had the same time that Reagan was
elected they elected Ortega in the most
fair elections ever documented in in
Latin American history and and I'm just
I would have a real hard time continuing
to be nice if I was a Nicaraguan after
the historical oppression that our
country is put upon a plane could you
document that last claim over and over
we heard from Oliver North and the
Reagan administration that Nicaragua was
a totalitarian communist dictatorship I
think North said that Nicaragua was the
only country in Central America that
doesn't have a democracy and even
liberals have picked up this refrain how
there's no democracy in Nicaragua it's a
one-party totalitarian state I saw an
op-ed piece in The New York Times just
this week that cited in one breath chile
cuba nicaragua and paraguay as examples
of latin american countries that had
one-party states and no democracy what
is your answer to that very frequent
charge well that's the line the
the government has been doing and I find
it totally false there were seven
parties that participated in the
election and they all had equal airtime
equal press time equal monies to work
with and the Senate East is legitimately
won that election and I think what's the
interesting they didn't win with a large
majority as they they won 60% yeah they
were anticipating about 80% and they won
60% because it was open people were not
intimidated to vote for the Senate ease
because people could vote for whoever
they wanted they did have a huge turnout
it was like a 90 percent turnout to vote
and you know when we think of our
pitiful turnouts for voting in
comparison you think of what is a real
democracy
you know I'm rather envious of that the
El Salvador and if you want to come to
make a comparison in El Salvador the
elections that they have are very the
people are have a certain number and
card so that everybody the government
knows how they voted and people are
intimidated to vote a certain way and
there are many documentation of military
of military oppression in places where
the vote we would be going on more left
to a more leftist party and there really
are no leftist parties that are allowed
to function in El Salvador
so Nicaragua is much more democratic
than El Salvador which is the country
our government is supporting in the
election they were about couple parties
to the left of the sana nieces and a
couple or so to the right of the Sun
yeah Senate the Senate nieces were the
moderate party in the elections now
there's still some conservative or
right-wing opposition parties that are
functioning and also participating in
the their Congress yes but all the
parties that were in the elections
participate in the in the Congress the
ultra right-wing party which was the one
that we were that we heard so much about
because they boycotted the elections
that was of their own choice they
probably boycotting was a smart thing
because they didn't have enough support
to even make a dent but so they are not
allowed to work in the Congress either
since they
boycotting and but the seven parties
that were which are right and left
parties all put the Constitution the new
constitution that was drafted together
working together which the ratified did
you see other evidence of forms of
democracy in Nicaragua in many countries
in the world like Nicaragua democracy
means something a bit different than
just voting in elections there's
neighborhood committees there's workers
democracy in the factories there's
peasant cooperatives and democratic
organization of Agriculture in the
countryside did you experience any of
this when you were on your trip this
summer to Nicaragua or previously I
enjoyed it a lot that what I saw and
learned of the flexibility of the Senate
kneestr government it's obvious from the
beginning if you really study what
they've been doing that they've been
trying to help and they've been trying
to help the poor first and but where
they make a judgement that is wrong or
that doesn't work very well where they
receive feedback from the people and
they changed they make a change towards
that for example every week the
president still goes and meets the
people in a meeting called gotta apply
both to face the people and people will
come up the poorest campus you know can
go up and start dialoguing with the
president and president saying well we
didn't get a shipment of seeds just up
to end time this year and and or
whatever needs changing and the
government readily admits mistakes and
and makes a change to to make the
situation better well they made a
significant change in their farm policy
didn't they from cooperatives to
individual smaller land holdings private
farmers yeah the first brainstorm of the
government was that people would be more
happy on cooperatives working together
they would have more strength they would
be able to have more machinery because
it would be donated to the whole
cooperative and they would be able to
have huge crops that they could market
more easily and make themselves
wealthier as a cooperative but a lot of
people while a lot of people still do
love to be on a cooperative as a
community like that many people they
found out want to have their own land so
a new reform is in put in place to let
people have more individual plots and so
that so that everybody is happy with
what they're getting and yet they've set
up organizations so the large landowners
are organized and they're highly
influential in the government and
protecting their land yes from any type
of redistribution yes there's a lot of
private virtually everything that you
asked about is privately owned and
Nicaragua as you walk around well now
we've read there there has been a clamp
down to some degree on civil liberties
because of the problems created by the
war - what was the extent now we know
that the one of the opposition
newspapers was shut down and some radio
stations in a church radio station was
shut down what else happened in this
regard as far as being able to to rally
I believe in groups you have to get a
permit to do that the I've had a hard
time finding specifics on what kind of
liberties were more clamped down upon
because as you go to Nicaragua I mean
even as we went this summer we were free
to go anywhere we wanted we were free to
speak any way we wanted people freely
speak to you and criticize ago nobody
had any problem giving us their beef and
usually the beef is directed to my
government rather than the Sandinistas
government although I was staying in a
hotel there that was obviously run by
conservative family and they were
criticizing the government openly as
with all the people who are sitting
around
they were having discussions where there
were different points of views just like
you get in the US so the people didn't
seem to be hesitant to speak out against
the government when they felt the desire
to their yeah you don't find that kind
of dialogue in L sounds not for long
but now they have as a result of the
Arya's plan they have rescinded a lot of
these things or all of them how much how
many of these things are actually done
away with and how many more freedoms are
they allowing now as far as I understand
it says it was before the they were
implemented up to it was about two years
ago I think they were implemented
because the war was getting so fierce
and they were implemented to no greater
extent than we implemented similar
restrictions during our wars over 1 in 2
and any other country does but they have
been released now under the plan and
she's saying seem to be not as normal in
the the could the critical radio
stations are back on and the La Prensa
has been opened up and they've been
amazing to me amazingly the gentle on
the opposition because for instance the
mando a Bravo the bishop there was
actually supporting the Contras and even
getting money from the CIA according to
results the reports that we we saw and
so I can't imagine and they also let the
La Prensa publish pro contra things and
knowing also the parental apprentice was
getting American money to operate on
can you imagine during world war two if
we'd let the pro-nazi Papers operate and
with German money no way there does
I doubt that LaPenta was a big joke for
people in my neighborhood when I was
living in Nicaragua they would come up
and show me the newspaper and say
because there's such a big deal made
here about censorship and they would
show me a newspaper that was covered
from front to back of criticizing the
government say see how the censorship
here in this country you can't say
anything against the government you know
it sarcastically speaking of course and
the the paper I found some really
strange articles in it like once I read
a review of torture in the world in
government instituted torture and it is
all of the countries supposedly that did
torture in the world were all East Bloc
countries according to this newspaper
film in this countries but never a
capitalist country now El Salvador Chile
or paragraph no and in our government
that that is it's documented that our
government trains torture in Latin
America
so it's blatant propaganda really
laprincia and liberals are always
squawking about this new century novella
print the Prensa as if this is evidence
that it's a totalitarian state in
Nicaraguan they never point out who owns
and runs and finances the print so what
had actually printed what its policies
which was just blatantly Pro contra at a
time they're having a civil war La
Prensa follows the blueprint the CIA
blueprint of how to take over a
newspaper it it shut down right after
the Revolution and eighty percent of the
people working for it were fired or left
and then it reopened in a totally
different format and a lot of the
stories I'm sure that have been censored
have been written in Washington DC let's
talk about the compare the penal system
and prison system in Nicaragua with that
of El Salvador we talked about the El
Salvador repression terrible system in
the prisons and torture and rape of
women what about in Nicaragua we did go
to a prison in Nicaragua and it was very
impressive prison I wouldn't expect our
prisons here in the States to be so
civilized they had classes going on they
had workshops teaching the prisoners had
to have a profession because most most
people become criminals because they
don't have a focus in life and they
don't have a profession to follow in and
they had a carpentry shop for example
where the prisoners would make their own
choice they could go to that carpenter
shop or they could go to some other kind
of workshop and they would be making
school desks and school chairs and the
profits from selling those two back to
the government would be to get benefits
for themselves in the prison and you
know better foods and different
surprises and then and also to have a
little something stashed away from when
I got out of prison they also teach him
how to read and write then as we walked
through the community area the communal
area in the prison there were school
classes going on on all sides of this
and what would put was a political
prisoners or what were some of the
reasons for the people being in the
prisons there were some political
prisoners and criminals all together and
it was there was not a separate place
for anyone the I understand that the
Contras Contra prisoners of war are also
put into these prisons as well they have
different degrees of prisons in
Nicaragua they have the maximum security
and then it goes down to several
different layers I presume this was a
medium-security prison that where we
were whereas they have some others that
are totally free with no gates or guards
that are more of a community of village
which is kind of the last step before
letting people go back into the society
to try to function as a normal citizen
Kathleen you were there during the
cultural war which has been of course
going on for years did you have any
exposure to some of the actual events of
the war see any evidence of the
suffering that the Nicaraguan people
have experienced as a result of the war
this two-week trip my only exposure was
that rally that we we went to a rally
Masaya which was called Maria mujer was
a festival for the for to celebrate the
mother the Mary Virgin and delegations
came from all over the country to this
rally but several two groups that were
on their way to the rally were ambushed
by the Contras and eleven people were
killed women and children these were not
soldiers at all as which is usual of a
contra attack and so instead of a
festival it was a commemoration and it
was very sorrowful and all the joyful
costumes and decorations no but people
were not smiling whereas whereas they
would have otherwise it was the first
case of a priest having been killed by
the Contras and so this was a big blow
to such a heavy Catholic country and and
it was a real step up in them for for
the atrocities of the contrasts we went
to a resettlement village why would they
have resettlement villages in Nicaragua
I can understand in El Salvador where
people would be coming into the city to
either seeking employment or fear of the
bombing but is there that much a
disruption in the countryside by the
countries that people are coming into
the city
there certainly are as a matter of fact
it's become a big tool by the u.s.
saying well you're taking people from
their homes the center needs to
government is removing you know for
example in mosquito resettlement
programs and and when actually the war
in them in the mountain areas where
people do have their villages and is
disrupt is disrupted these people's
lives and the resettlement has been
going to villages that have been built
by European aid and thus enemies of the
people that go to the villages helping
each other with the materials building
these beautiful homes and we went to
visit one impromptu we were rained out
of where we were supposed to go so we
went to another one and so we didn't
feel like anything had been set up for
us at all and these
villages were the houses were very nice
its little little Swiss type built
houses and and the community was very
tight and the people in the community
did they're protected themselves they
had their own militia to defend
themselves against conscious attacks
because they were still in the war zone
this was up in the northern area
although this wasn't right on the border
where they had lived before about
everybody in the town had experienced
some sort of atrocity or lost a family
member to the Contra battle and so had
felt the need to escape from that area
and so I did meet a wonderful a woman
that I started speaking to while our
group was meeting with the rest of the
people and she said that she would not
go back to where she lived before even
if the war stopped because she enjoyed
this new community and the facilities
they had so much better everyone had
their own outhouse and they had a
farming area and their own animals and
and then she took me back to her house
to show me her house which was a I mean
they're really simple as can be expected
but it was a lot more than she had had
before and then that most people have in
Latin American countries Kathleen how
many of them Rooskies did you see down
there and then nasty Cubans I didn't
meet any Russians I ran into a couple of
Cubans the most people that I ran into
there were Europeans ran into people
from Korea from Germany from England
from France most of the people I ran
into they were from Italy of the 52
organizations that are European
organizations that helped Nicaragua
twelve of those are Italian and most of
them are sponsored by private a private
aid from those countries
they are agricultural and an educational
and health are the three main areas that
the Europeans help Nicaragua and it's
basically solidarity assistance because
they everybody realizes the situation
that Nicaragua is in and our government
seems to be quite isolated in its
opinion of Nicaragua worldwide people on
the on both sides east and west buck are
helping Nicaragua very openly of the
Arias peace plan to look forward to do
you have a sense that that might
actually work in Nicaragua that there is
a possibility for peaceful settlement in
that region yes I think that the Central
American government's getting together
as they have on this plan and even the
right-wing governments and electric
governments coming to an agreement on
what their countries need Central
America has to solve Central America's
problems that's what it comes down to
and our government has to stop
interfering and trying to control
Central America because they're not a
puppet because they have autonomy
they're beautiful countries the people
are wonderful and have a lot more
patience and I think many of us would
under the same circumstances of
oppression and there's a statement made
to me by someone on this trip I can't
remember who it was but they said El
Salvador and Nicaragua are really the
same after I've been going over how much
I don't know how much they contrasted
they said in both countries that people
want freedom
you
[Music]